and welcome to hannity and we begin this
monday night with a fox news alert
tonight russian forces are still very
much stalled in the north around keeve
and in the south the city of mario poll
continues to face a barrage of
indiscriminate shelling now its
residents are completely cut off from
water power supplies one ap reporter
inside the city described it this way
quote time was measured from one shell
to the next with bombed out apartment
buildings and an endless line of dead
people and dead children on the radio
the only thing that could be heard was
the following constantly repeated
message mario pool is surrounded
surrender your weapons and yet the city
refuses to surrender if russia wants to
take ukraine it looks like they're going
to have to fight for every single inch
but the situation is dire on the ground
tonight in kearsen russian soldiers
opened fire this is terrible to watch on
many peaceful protesters hitting
innocent civilians yet again scores of
men women and children murdered every
single day by putin's soldiers and
estimates of as many as 10 million
refugees or more have fled the country
now there are new reports of mercenaries
being sent to ukraine by putin with
orders to assassinate president
zielinski and his entire family so make
no mistake vladimir putin is waging a
baseless war of aggression against a
sovereign nation my position on this has
been very clear although there are
people that are so stupid in the mob in
the media they have no clue there's no
ambiguity where i stand as i have said
over and over and over again no matter
how bad this situation becomes in
ukraine there can never be any us boots
on the ground and i also add there can't
be a no-fly zone where we are in direct
combat with russian uh with russia in
the air we are not the world's police
force we can no longer send our national
treasure your sons and daughters our
sons and daughters to fight and die in a
conventional war pushed by politicians
frankly on both sides they all start out
gung-ho they start the war they never
fight to win the war then the war gets
politicized after whatever period of
time then the politicians say oh never
mind the soldiers get pulled out uh like
the islamic emirates of afghanistan we
end up back at square one after so much
sacrifice and bloodshed and so many dead
americans and so many injured americans
never again and we do need to learn the
lessons from history no more vietnam's
no more afghanistans but we can and we
should learn from history what does work
and i'll explain that in a minute in
short you get weapons and supplies to
our allies in this case in ukraine so
they can fight and win this war by
themselves they have shown great courage
they have shown the will to fight and
the will to defeat vladimir putin's
invasion now my position is based on two
very specific foreign policy successes
we should learn from them the first is
what's called the reagan doctrine here's
how ronald reagan then president
described it in 1985 take a look
and tonight
we declare anew to our fellow citizens
of the world
freedom is not the sole prerogative of a
chosen few
it is the universal right of all god's
children
we must stand by all our democratic
allies
and we must not break faith with those
who are risking their lives on every
continent from afghanistan to nicaragua
to defy soviet-supported aggression
and secure rights which have been hours
from birth support for freedom fighters
is self-defense
we as conservatives we believe in
natural rights god-given rights that
were endowed by our creator that rights
don't come from
our government instead of sending waves
of u.s ground forces to foreign lands to
fight long bloody conventional wars well
ronald reagan armed our allies
so they could fight for their own
freedom in their own countries he did
this with nicaragua with the contras
against the sandinistas and daniel
ortega they were fighting the
soviet-backed you know communists there
and he also did it with the mujahideen
albeit imperfect people in afghanistan
and by the way reagan never put a single
american boot on the ground to fight
there none but instead of cowering in
fear or attempting to appease the
soviets he stood up to them at every
turn without starting a long
conventional war and guess what it
worked the soviets were defeated in
afghanistan thanks to the stinger
missiles that ronald reagan reagan
provided them reagan knew that evil
especially in the form of an ism
communism fascism nazi ism
would spread like a cancer if left
unchecked and reagan called the former
soviet union the evil empire that's why
reagan said quote support for freedom
fighters is self-defense president
reagan was right his policy succeeded
peace through strength worked in 2014 we
witnessed the rise of isis in the middle
east and it happened on that's right joe
biden and barack obama's watch because
they did nothing not only did these
terrorists take over huge and large
portions of iran and syria but they also
ripped through europe and the united
states with a wave of terrorist attacks
that is until donald j trump was sworn
into office in january of 2017 and that
now brings us to the second foreign
policy success another doctrine we
should learn from and that's the trump
doctrine shortly after taking office
president trump bombed the isis
caliphate into oblivion and by the way
the one that joe and obama allowed to
grow and president trump used new
american sophisticated weaponry
technology and air power in the form of
drones without a traditional ground
force trump repelled isis fighters in a
short amount of time defeated the entire
caliphate he fought that fight to win
and when he did and even took out the
leader of isis l baghdadi and his
associates and president trump also used
air strikes to counter syria and iran
including a drone strike that
successfully killed iranian terrorists
solemnani member on the tarmac and you
can listen to president trump describe
this in 2019. take a look baghdadi's
demise demonstrates america's
relentless pursuit
of terrorist leaders
and our commitment to the enduring
and total defeat of isis and other
terrorist organizations
last night at my direction the united
states military successfully
executed a flawless precision strike
that killed the number one
terrorist anywhere in the world
qasim salameni
under my leadership america's policy is
unambiguous to terrorists who harm or
intend to harm any american
we will find you we will eliminate you
we will always protect our diplomats
service members all americans and our
allies no boots on the ground and
american victory and donald and
president trump's doctrine was very very
strategic and very effective and it
worked and it sent a message of strength
to the rest of the world and all the
other despots and all the other
dictators uh and all of those that had
territorial ambitions of their own now
the u.s cannot use its air power in
ukraine putin is a much different enemy
than say baghdadi or solemani but one
thing does remain constant aggression
from hostile actors will only get worse
and worse until they're stopped and
right now thus far the ukrainian people
are quite bravely upending vladimir's
territorial expansion if ukraine
prevails putin's ability to attack other
countries especially nato members is
greatly diminished and peace can once
again return to the continent of europe
without a catastrophic world war that's
why it's very important that the u.s
supply ukraine with the weapons and the
supplies they need to fight their war
and bring vladimir to his knees the way
reagan supplied the mujahideen this is
something i have said many many times
but oddly enough over there rolling
stone magazine the great uh let's see
journalistic integrity that they have
and other liars in the media mob are
actually accusing me they're saying
hannity is parroting russian propaganda
and supporting vladimir putin um
well not really because i went out on
the limb and i told the truth and i've
been saying it since before the election
in 2020. joe biden is weak he is frail
and a cognitive wreck and everybody
knows it every poll now shows the
majority of the american people see it
and by the way our friends see it and
unfortunately the world's hostile actors
and hostile regimes see it also for the
last two years i've pointed this out
well before putin's invasion of ukraine
i warned that biden's mental weakness
will have serious significant
ramifications across the globe take a
look
joe let's be honest and never
particularly a smart or a bright guy but
what we're now seeing sadly for him is a
hollow shell of his former self a total
complete cognitive mess what's really
sad is the reality that if we can all
see it so can america's enemies and we
have real enemies in iran in china north
korea russia vladimir putin doesn't
respect or fear joe biden now america's
enemies all over the world they are
smelling blood in the water we see
russia fully emboldened they're
threatening to invade ukraine we have a
president and a vice president they are
not up to this job but i know this and
you know this america's enemies they're
also seeing everything we're seeing and
sadly tonight as a result the world and
our country is less safe and it is less
secure
unfortunately i was right russia invaded
ukraine in part because putin did not
fear did not respect joe biden
especially after his debacle in the
islamic emirates of afghanistan if
you're keeping track like we are it is
day 219
since joe biden abandoned our fellow
americans behind enemy lines and by the
way joe biden is so clearly not up to
the job with each passing day it just
gets worse and worse and worse and i
wish i was wrong but i'm not take a look
the first lady's husband uh contracting
covet but uh look at this room and what
you see
pardon
that's right
she's fine
it's me
that's not together
the second lady the first gentleman from
mom to get her kid on the internet to be
able to do their homework has to pull
into mcdonald's parking lot
i mean for real
that's what's happening
this law is going to put an end to all
that
going to put people in a much different
position to be able to determine their
own
their own judgments about when to sell
their cattle
and a pound of ukrainian people the
proud proud people pound for pound ready
to fight with every inch of earnings
they have is becoming
much more informed on
the um
the motives of um
some of the political
players
i don't show you this to mock or laugh
at joe biden it is sad i used to laugh
at it but it's so serious it just isn't
funny anymore instead this should serve
as a daily reminder that our country and
the world is less safe with that guy as
president and now a majority of you the
american people see what i was talking
about during the campaign and that is
joe's declining cognitive state and
every hostile actor and every hostile
regime that studies the us guess what on
the world stage they see it also and
with that said no one has been more
anti-putin than yours truly vladimir
clear and simple he invaded a sovereign
country he's killing innocent men women
and children he's an evil war criminal
he's responsible for the bloodshed of
all of these people in ukraine he has
blood on his hands and as i've said many
times i hope somebody in his inner
circle maybe a general i don't know
maybe an advisor uh could take him out
uh by any means necessary and put an end
to this senseless war and death take a
look
now putin i've been saying it all week
it's interesting the media finally
picked it up putin has got to be stopped
by whatever means necessary one way or
another
it's a simple rule in life if you invade
an innocent country and you kill women
and children and men you forfeit your
right to lead a country and you forfeit
your right to live and i hope that
people around vladimir putin well i hope
they take action sooner than later
i hope and pray this war comes to an end
one way or another but sadly i doubt
biden's big trip to europe this week is
going to tip the scales earlier tonight
he gave a very well another bizarre
speech about a new world order
pay attention to this one
now is a time when things are shifting
we're going to they're going to be a new
world order out there and we've got to
lead it and we've got to unite the rest
of the free world and doing it
new world order i guess what what the
hell does it even mean oh that's right
joe wants to do a new deal give tens of
billions of dollars to iran let russia
broker the deal along with china uh
maybe even allow a 10 billion dollar
iranian russia uh nuclear facility to be
built uh and then sell let iran get rich
selling us oil or sending emissaries
over to venezuela
and trying to work out a deal with them
to buy their oil and begging opec that
keeps rejecting him to produce more oil
that we could produce right here in the
usa
that's not exactly projection of
leadership or freedom uh but i digress
tonight there are a lot of opinions
about putin's invasion on ukraine and
what our role should be make no mistake
we are at a very very critical juncture
whether we like to admit it or not we're
just one border away from what would be
a world war based on our alliance and
article five with other nato countries
an attack against one is an attack
against all but the so-called leader of
the free world just cannot bring himself
to put in a full week of work because
before his big trip to europe well joe
took the weekend off in delaware
relaxing at the beach enjoying nice
leisurely rides on his uh bicycle hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else